This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. About an hour northwest of Madrid, an enormous stone crucifix rises 500 feet out of a rocky mountaintop. It's so big you can see it from miles away. Beneath the cross, there's a sprawling Benedictine monastery and a basilica carved out of the mountain. This place is called the Valley of the Fallen,
这里是《99%隐形》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。在马德里西北约一小时车程的地方，一座巨大的石制十字架从岩石山顶拔地而起，高达500英尺。它非常宏伟，几英里外都能看到。在十字架下方，有一座庞大的本笃会修道院和一座从山体中开凿出来的巴西利卡大教堂。这个地方被称为“烈士谷”。
and it's likely the most controversial monument in Spain. The valley is synonymous with Francisco Franco, the general who ruled Spain from the end of its bloody civil war in 1939, until his death in 1975. That's reporter Jennifer Omani. When Franco died, he became the valley's most notorious inhabitant. His body was buried under a huge stone slab. But as the decades passed after his death, anger about the monument grew.
它很可能是西班牙最具争议的纪念碑。这个山谷是弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥的代名词，这位将军从1939年西班牙血腥内战结束起，一直统治该国直到1975年去世。这是记者詹妮弗·奥马尼。佛朗哥去世后，他成了山谷中最臭名昭著的“居民”。他的遗体被埋在一块巨大的石板下。但随着他死后几十年的流逝，人们对这座纪念碑的愤怒与日俱增。
People began to push for the removal of Franco's body. They argued there was no place in a democracy for a monument exulting a man who had tortured and killed thousands of Spaniards in the name of fascism. And then, in October of 2019. Now the Spanish dictator Francisco Franco died 44 years ago. Today his remains were moved from the valley of the fallen. Franco's body was disinterred, his coffin packed into a helicopter and then flown to a graveyard
人们开始推动移走佛朗哥的遗体。他们认为，在一个民主国家，不应有纪念碑去歌颂一个以法西斯主义之名折磨并杀害了成千上万西班牙人的独裁者。然后，在2019年10月。西班牙独裁者弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥于44年前去世。今天，他的遗骸从烈士谷被移走。佛朗哥的遗体被掘出，棺木被装上直升机，随后飞往一座墓地，
on the outskirts of the city to be re-buried. Despite all his torturing and murdering, Franco still has fans in Spain. Some see him as the emblem of a traditional Spanish Catholic life, and some actually like his fascist ideology and would like to see it make a comeback. And so when his body was removed, hundreds of his supporters gathered at the new cemetery to wheel swastikers and Franco era flags and to perform the fascist salute in his honor. In fact, I lived 19 years under Franco and Spain was a wonderful country. Now it's a shit.
在城市郊区重新安葬。尽管他犯下了种种酷刑和谋杀罪行，佛朗哥在西班牙仍有拥护者。有些人视他为西班牙传统天主教生活的象征，还有些人确实喜欢他的法西斯意识形态，并希望看到它卷土重来。因此，当他的遗体被移走时，数百名支持者聚集在新墓地，挥舞着纳粹标志和佛朗哥时代的旗帜，并以法西斯礼向他致敬。事实上，我在佛朗哥统治下生活了19年，西班牙曾是一个美好的国家。现在它烂透了。
One of the protesters told me that she lived for 19 years under Franco, and that Spain was a marvelous country back then. She said that dictators' spirit would always be in the valley and in her heart. Even if you're not familiar with Franco, this story might sound familiar to you. You got your fascists, you got your anti-fascists, and there's this monument honoring a very bad man from the past that people are arguing about. But this story is different because the valley of the fallen isn't just a monument. It is also a mass grave.
其中一名抗议者告诉我，她在佛朗哥统治下生活了19年，那时的西班牙是一个了不起的国家。她说，独裁者的精神将永远留在山谷和她的心中。即使你不熟悉佛朗哥，这个故事听起来可能也很耳熟。你有法西斯分子，有反法西斯分子，还有一座纪念过去某个大恶人的纪念碑，人们正为此争论不休。但这个故事有所不同，因为烈士谷不仅仅是一座纪念碑，它还是一个万人坑。
There are tens of thousands of other bodies still trapped in the Basilica beneath where Franco used to lie. Many were ordinary civilians killed by Franco's security forces during the height of the Civil War. And for years, their families have been trying to get them out. The story of the Valley of the Fallen can be traced all the way back to the mid-1930s, when Spain found itself torn into different political directions. The Republic, Aninia Bonita, the beautiful girl. Joyful demonstrations throughout Spain
在佛朗哥曾经躺卧的巴西利卡大教堂下方，仍有数万具遗体被困在那里。许多人是内战高峰期被佛朗哥安全部队杀害的普通平民。多年来，他们的家人一直试图将他们带出来。烈士谷的故事可以追溯到20世纪30年代中期，当时西班牙发现自己被撕裂向不同的政治方向。共和国，“美丽的女孩”（Aninia Bonita）。西班牙各地举行了欢乐的示威活动，
agreed to the proclamation of the Republic. In 1936, the country was a new democracy, just a few years removed from monarchy when a group of left-wing anti-clarical republicans won the elections. This horrified the right-wing Catholics in the country. That included Francisco Franco, a general in the Spanish army. After the election, Franco banded together with other right-wing military leaders to carry out a coup. They believed they were on a divine crusade.
赞同共和国的宣告。1936年，这个国家是一个新兴的民主国家，距离君主制仅几年时间，当时一群左翼反教权共和党人赢得了选举。这让国内的右翼天主教徒感到恐惧。其中包括西班牙军队的一名将军弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥。选举后，佛朗哥联合其他右翼军事领导人发动了政变。他们相信自己是在进行一场神圣的十字军东征。
What began as a military coup that had almost three years of civil war? The right-wingers gradually seized control of Spain. Their death squads rounded up suspected leftists and then paraded them through villages and shot them. For both sides, political opponents became enemies to be hunted down and killed. This is purification on La Peña, her grandfather Manuel and great uncle Antonio were among Franco's victims.
这场始于军事政变的行动演变成了近三年的内战。右翼分子逐渐夺取了西班牙的控制权。他们的死亡小队搜捕疑似左翼分子，将他们游街示众并枪决。对双方而言，政治对手都成了必须被追捕和杀害的敌人。这是普里菲卡·佩尼亚（Purificación La Peña），她的祖父曼努埃尔和叔祖父安东尼奥都是佛朗哥的受害者。
When I met her, she showed me photos of them as handsome young men back in the 1930s. Manuel worked as a village vet, caring for the animals of local farmers. His brother Antonio was an iron worker. Both men had supported the leftist who won the elections, and both had joined a union, making them targets for the right-wing nationalists. Manuel was working in the field one day in July 1936 when a group of Franco's men rolled up in a truck. They grabbed Purific Atheons' grandfather and the other workers and took them to a nearby
当我见到她时，她向我展示了他们20世纪30年代作为英俊年轻人的照片。曼努埃尔是一名乡村兽医，照顾当地农民的牲畜。他的兄弟安东尼奥是一名铁匠。两人都支持赢得选举的左翼人士，并加入了工会，这使他们成为了右翼民族主义者的目标。1936年7月的一天，曼努埃尔正在田里干活，一群佛朗哥的手下开着卡车赶到。他们抓走了普里菲卡的祖父和其他工人，把他们带到了附近的一座
jail. Her grandfather was killed and left in a ditch. Her great uncle was murdered a few months later. Over the years, words spread through the village that the ravine where manwell was killed was filling up with bodies, but it would take a long time for the family to find out exactly what had happened. And they weren't the only ones left without answers, something similar was playing out for families across the country.
监狱。她的祖父被杀并被扔进沟里。她的叔祖父几个月后也被谋杀。多年来，村里传言曼努埃尔被杀的峡谷里堆满了尸体，但这个家庭花了很长时间才查清到底发生了什么。他们并不是唯一没有得到答案的人，全国各地的家庭都在经历类似的事情。
The Spanish Civil War, like any other, unleashed the passions of centuries of hatred. The killing was unrestrained. By 1939, the Civil War was over, and Spain was in ruins. At least 400,000 people had died. Half of them were civilians who faced torture, assassination, and the unexplained disappearances of their family members. A network of mass graves now scarred the Spanish landscape.
西班牙内战像其他任何战争一样，释放了几个世纪以来积压的仇恨。杀戮毫无节制。到1939年，内战结束，西班牙满目疮痍。至少有40万人死亡。其中一半是平民，他们面临着酷刑、暗杀以及家人莫名失踪的痛苦。一个万人坑网络现在在西班牙的土地上留下了伤疤。
Some contained thousands of bodies. It's estimated that Spain still has 114,000 missing people dating back to that time. But Franco wasn't interested in what happened to the bodies of his enemies, at least not at first. He was too busy consolidating his power. As the great superpowers of the world took up sides in World War II, he decided not to fight, focusing his energies on fully crushing his
有些坑里埋着数千具尸体。据估计，西班牙至今仍有11.4万人失踪，可以追溯到那个时期。但佛朗哥对敌人的尸体下落并不感兴趣，至少起初是这样。他忙于巩固自己的权力。当世界超级大国在第二次世界大战中选边站时，他决定不参战，将精力集中在彻底粉碎国内的
opposition at home. In an official declaration, Generalissimo Francisco Franco states that his government will not join the German Italian-Japanese alliance against communism. But he says that he will extrope communism in Spain. The country now had a single political party and protest was effectively banned. Franco became known as El Caldillo, the supreme leader. And in a very savvy move, he continued to cultivate the backing of the Catholic Church. Franco was not a particularly religious man, but he adopted the idea very cleverly that his war efforts was a religious crusade.
反对派上。在官方声明中，弗朗西斯科·佛朗哥大元帅表示，他的政府不会加入德意日反共联盟。但他表示，他将在西班牙铲除共产主义。该国现在只有一个政党，抗议活动实际上被禁止。佛朗哥被称为“领袖”（El Caudillo）。他采取了一个非常精明的举措，继续培养天主教会的支持。佛朗哥并不是一个特别虔诚的人，但他非常聪明地采纳了一个观点，即他的战争努力是一场宗教十字军东征。
This is Paul Preston. He's one of the leading scholars of the Spanish Civil War and of Franco's regime. And this guaranteed him the support of the Catholic Church internationally. Which meant Franco could operate with relative impunity. He went about taking away many of the rights that Spaniards had gained during the 1930s. Women, for example, lost the right to divorce their husbands and have abortions and they could no longer work outside the home without permission. Men, on the other hand, could kill their wives for adultery.
这是保罗·普雷斯顿。他是研究西班牙内战和佛朗哥政权的顶尖学者之一。这保证了他获得国际天主教会的支持，意味着佛朗哥可以相对不受惩罚地行事。他着手剥夺了西班牙人在20世纪30年代获得的多项权利。例如，女性失去了与丈夫离婚和堕胎的权利，未经许可不能在家庭外工作。另一方面，男性可以因妻子通奸而杀死她们。
The government banned regional languages like Basque and Catalan. The Catholic Church ruled over every aspect of most Spaniards lives. The ideas of francoism have been pumped out from church pulpits. They're being pumped out in schools, the people who in principle would not have supported Franco were basically forced either to accept these ideas or go into what we call inner exile, in other words, to go into a world of silence.
政府禁止了巴斯克语和加泰罗尼亚语等地区语言。天主教会统治着大多数西班牙人生活的方方面面。佛朗哥主义的思想从教堂讲坛中传出，在学校里灌输。那些原则上不支持佛朗哥的人基本上被迫要么接受这些思想，要么进入所谓的“内心流亡”，换句话说，进入一个沉默的世界。
And now that Franco had gained absolute power over the country, he wanted a monument to immortalize his great triumph. It is to be for him what the pyramids were to the Pharaohs. Franco commissioned the valley of the fallen in 1940. The building, he said, would rival the grandeur of ancient monuments. And then because he was Franco, he went about building the monument in the most fascist way possible, relying on the forced labour of his political prisoners. The three camps were controlled by the brigade of the civil guards. We were counted every three hours to make sure that nobody has escaped.
现在佛朗哥已经获得了对国家的绝对权力，他想要一座纪念碑来永垂他的伟大胜利。它对他而言，就像金字塔对法老一样。佛朗哥于1940年下令修建烈士谷。他说，这座建筑将媲美古代纪念碑的宏伟。而且因为他是佛朗哥，他以最法西斯的方式建造了这座纪念碑，依靠政治犯的强迫劳动。三个营地由国民警卫队旅控制。我们每三小时被清点一次，以确保没有人逃跑。
This is Nicolas Sanchez, Albert Noff. Back in the 1940s, he was a college student in Madrid, and he got involved in anti-Franco organizing. After getting caught handing out pro-democracy pamphlets, Nicolas was sentenced to work at the Valley of the Fallen. We had to sleep in the barracks, and well, at seven o'clock, we were supposed to be working. Because of Nicolasolas' University education,
这是尼古拉斯·桑切斯·阿尔沃诺斯。20世纪40年代，他是马德里的一名大学生，参与了反佛朗哥的组织活动。因散发支持民主的传单被捕后，尼古拉斯被判在烈士谷服苦役。我们必须睡在营房里，嗯，七点钟我们就得开始工作。由于尼古拉斯受过大学教育，
he was put to work in the office, suffering papers around for prison officials and filling in endless forms. But as he walked to and from his barracks each day, he saw men carving rock on pitiful rations of food and working with dynamite without protection. Very harsh work and obviously there were some people that were killed. The construction of the Valley of the Fallen took an enormous human toll.
他被安排在办公室工作，为监狱官员处理文件并填写无休止的表格。但每天往返营房时，他都会看到工人们在可怜的口粮下凿石，并在没有保护的情况下使用炸药。工作非常艰苦，显然有些人因此丧生。烈士谷的建设造成了巨大的人员伤亡。
An estimated 40,000 prisoners worked on the project, some died from exhaustion. Others, in hell, pulverized granite and were killed by lung diseases many years later. Franco had initially conceived of the valley of the fallen as a gravesite, much less a mass grave, but it would become one thanks to Franco's twisted response to pressure from one of Spain's main allies. The Americans relied on Spain as one of their European partners during the Cold War. And when they heard about Franco's plans for the Valley of the Fallen, they started to get nervous. The monument was shaping up to be pretty confrontational and divisive.
据估计有4万名囚犯参与了该项目，一些人死于精疲力竭。另一些人在地狱般的条件下粉碎花岗岩，多年后死于肺病。佛朗哥最初将烈士谷设想为墓地，甚至不是万人坑，但由于他对西班牙主要盟友之一施加的压力做出了扭曲的反应，它最终成为了一个万人坑。美国在冷战期间将西班牙视为欧洲伙伴之一。当他们听说佛朗哥修建烈士谷的计划时，他们开始感到紧张。这座纪念碑看起来极具对抗性和分裂性。
The Americans hoped Franco would dial it back a bit, to make it a place that memorialized all the country's war dead, not just the Catholic crusaders. And so Franco declared the Valley of the Fallen to be a place of reconciliation, a place where the dead, for both sides of the Civil War, would be laid to rest. But then, once again,
美国人希望佛朗哥能稍微收敛一点，将其建成一个纪念全国所有战争死难者的地方，而不仅仅是天主教十字军。于是，佛朗哥宣布烈士谷是一个“和解之地”，一个让内战双方死者安息的地方。但随后，再一次，
Franco went about making that happen in the most fascist way possible. Well, so Franco and I, well, we're going to do this as a reconciliation. What do you think about the opinion? That's the way possible. What if he got the idea? Says that Franco ordered his people to bring him bodies from mass graves and cemeteries all over Spain. They dug the bodies up without permission and jumbled them together in boxes.
佛朗哥以最法西斯的方式去实现这一目标。好吧，佛朗哥和我，我们要把这作为一种和解。你觉得这个意见怎么样？这是最可能的方式。他怎么会有这个想法？据说佛朗哥下令手下从西班牙各地的万人坑和墓地把尸体运来。他们未经许可就挖出尸体，把它们混在一起装进盒子里。
Then they drove them to the valley, where they were re-buried in the crypt near the Basilica. Finally completed, the valley opened to the public in 1959. Nearly two decades later, when Franco finally died of heart failure, he too was buried at the valley of La Falaune. He was laid to rest in a grand basilica above the bodies of the Spaniards he had tortured, killed, and then re-barried in a mass grave, where their families couldn't find them. And with Franco gone, Spain suddenly confronted a new future without El Galio.
然后他们把尸体运到山谷，重新埋葬在巴西利卡附近的地下室里。烈士谷最终于1959年向公众开放。近二十年后，当佛朗哥最终因心脏衰竭去世时，他也葬在了烈士谷。他被安葬在宏伟的巴西利卡大教堂中，就在他折磨、杀害并重新埋葬在万人坑中、让家属无法找到的西班牙人的遗体之上。随着佛朗哥的离去，西班牙突然面临着一个没有“领袖”的新未来。
Well, look, when Franco died, we were very happy to get rid of him. We were expecting that, and we had the freeze of full of champagne. The three years between Franco's death and the signing of a new constitution became known as the transition. The country moved from fascist dictatorship to multi-party democracy. And starting in the late 1970s, Spain finally got to do what the US, Britain and France had done more than a decade before. They got to have fun.
看，佛朗哥死的时候，我们很高兴摆脱了他。我们期待着那一刻，冰箱里都塞满了香槟。佛朗哥去世到签署新宪法之间的三年被称为“过渡期”。国家从法西斯独裁转向了多党民主。从20世纪70年代末开始，西班牙终于可以做美国、英国和法国十多年前做过的事了。他们可以享受生活了。
A new revolutionary movement sprang up in Madrid and became known as La Movida, Madelineia. La Movida has consumed Madrid, transforming the capital into Europe's new, moveable feast. Suddenly, Spaniards could drink, dance, have sex outside of marriage, and make music about it. The transition seemed to have ushered in a new Spain, but the elation felt after Franco's death was temporary. It's only after several years that you realize that new democracy hasn't solved all the problems that were brought by the dictatorship. For one thing, there were reminders of the dictatorship everywhere. There were statues of Franco and his collaborators in central plaza all over the country.
一场新的革命运动在马德里兴起，被称为“莫维达”（La Movida）。“莫维达”席卷了马德里，将首都变成了欧洲新的“流动的盛宴”。突然间，西班牙人可以喝酒、跳舞、婚外性行为，并为此创作音乐。过渡期似乎开启了一个新的西班牙，但佛朗哥死后的狂喜是暂时的。几年后你才会意识到，新的民主并没有解决独裁统治带来的所有问题。首先，独裁统治的痕迹随处可见。全国各地的中心广场上都有佛朗哥及其合作者的雕像。
His name was on street signs. And of course, the Valley of the Fallen served as a colossal reminder. How can you have a democracy and at the same time have a huge monument to the glory of the dictatorship built by political prisoners? But perhaps the biggest hurdle to fully addressing what had happened to the country under Franco was an agreement that became known as the pacto de la olvido, the pact of forgetting. It is simply an oblivion, an amnesty for everyone. Agreed to by everyone.
他的名字出现在街道标志上。当然，烈士谷作为一个巨大的提醒存在着。你怎么能既拥有民主，又同时拥有一座由政治犯建造的、歌颂独裁统治的巨大纪念碑呢？但也许全面解决佛朗哥统治下国家所发生之事的最大障碍，是一项被称为“遗忘协定”（Pacto del Olvido）的协议。这简直就是一种遗忘，一种对所有人的大赦。每个人都同意了。
At the heart of the pact of forgetting was legal forgiveness for all Franco-era crimes. It was a deal agreed to by parties on the right and the left. It was a massive compromise. The whole process of transition to democracy was a transaction. It was a deal. It was a negotiation. Paul Preston again. Moderation, compromise, sacrifice was the only chance
“遗忘协定”的核心是对所有佛朗哥时代的罪行进行法律上的宽恕。这是左右两派政党达成的一项交易。这是一个巨大的妥协。整个向民主过渡的过程是一场交易。这是一笔买卖。这是一场谈判。保罗·普雷斯顿再次说道。温和、妥协、牺牲是获得哪怕一丝民主的唯一机会。
of getting even a glimmer of democracy. So that's the context. The left agreed to the pact because they wanted their political prisoners freed and their political parties legalized. They wanted to be able to live in this new democracy without fear of being tortured or murdered. But it's time went on, they had to grapple with the fact that the amnesty applied to people on the right to. To, because we believe that good that someone from the East was a party for little
所以这就是背景。左派同意这项协定，因为他们希望政治犯获释，政党合法化。他们希望能够生活在这个新的民主国家中，而不必担心被折磨或谋杀。但随着时间的推移，他们不得不面对这样一个事实：大赦也适用于右派。因为我们相信，来自东方的某个人是……
that was left in political companies. Falsal Canalis was a left-wing activist back in the late 70s when the pact of forgetting went into effect. He knew back then that his father had disappeared during the Civil War when Falsal was just two years old, and he says that instead of making sure people on the left wouldn't be persecuted for their political views, the Amnesty Law was primarily used making sure people on the left wouldn't be persecuted for their political views, the Amnesty Law was primarily used to shield those on the right who'd killed civilians. Fausto says when he realized what had happened, he put his head in his hands, he felt he'd
那是左翼政治公司。福斯托·卡纳莱斯（Fausto Canales）是70年代末“遗忘协定”生效时的左翼活动家。他当时就知道他的父亲在内战期间失踪了，那时福斯托才两岁。他说，大赦法并没有确保左派人士不会因政治观点而受到迫害，反而主要被用来保护那些杀害平民的右派人士。福斯托说，当他意识到发生了什么时，他双手抱头，感到自己
been tricked. The pact created a culture of silence around the atrocities of Spain's past. It suppressed conversations about the killing of civilians during the Civil War and the long years of repression that followed. The pact basically said, let's just not talk about what happened. Let's move forward instead. And as for the Valley of the Fallen, it became something like a shrine to Franco. Fascists would visit it from all over Europe to pay their respects and would mark his death with
被欺骗了。这项协定在西班牙过去的暴行周围营造了一种沉默文化。它压制了关于内战期间平民被杀以及随后的长期镇压的讨论。协定基本上说，让我们不要谈论发生了什么。让我们向前看。至于烈士谷，它成了某种类似佛朗哥神殿的地方。来自欧洲各地的法西斯分子会来这里表达敬意，并每年在他的忌日用
flowers every year. Franco was remembered even as the pact insured that his crimes were slowly forgotten and erased. For people like Purific Atheon, the pact just didn't work. It was impossible to move forward without knowing exactly what had happened to her relatives. As time went on, her family and many others began to resist the taboo against speaking up. They began to talk about what they've been through. The whole tradition was a dream that didn't take the democracy, but it was true that
鲜花纪念他。尽管协定确保了他的罪行被慢慢遗忘和抹去，但佛朗哥仍被铭记。对于像普里菲卡·佩尼亚这样的人来说，协定根本不起作用。如果不确切知道亲人发生了什么，就不可能向前看。随着时间的推移，她的家人和许多其他人开始抵制这种禁忌。他们开始谈论自己的经历。整个传统是一个梦想，没有带来民主，但确实……
it was a dream. Porifica Fion says that during the 1980s, discussions that had long been kept quiet started to come out into the open. And even if people didn't want to listen, at least it was no longer unthinkable for families of victims to make their grievances known. And as families began to talk more about what happened to them, they also started to organize around an important goal. They wanted to find the bodies of their missing family members that had ended up in the mass
那是一个梦想。普里菲卡说，在20世纪80年代，长期被压制的讨论开始公开化。即使人们不想听，受害者家属表达不满也不再是不可想象的事情。随着家属们开始更多地谈论他们的遭遇，他们也开始围绕一个重要目标组织起来。他们想找到那些最终进入全国各地万人坑的失踪家属的遗体。
graves around the country. And they weren't going to wait for the government to give them permission. They began hiring forensic specialists and archaeologists to help them find and dig up the bodies themselves. The tea. Miguel and Hel, Kapape, works for an organization called Arrico. It carries out private exchumations for families who want to find their murdered relatives. As Miguel showed me around the headquarters, I noticed a wall of boxes and asked what they contained. He told me that inside were skeletons, some broken into pieces by torture
他们不会等待政府的许可。他们开始聘请法医专家和考古学家帮助他们寻找并亲自挖掘遗体。米格尔·安赫尔·卡帕佩（Miguel Ángel Capapé）为一家名为“Aranzadi”的组织工作。它为想要寻找被谋杀亲人的家庭进行私人挖掘。当米格尔带我参观总部时，我注意到墙上有一排盒子，问里面装的是什么。他告诉我，里面是骨骼，有些因酷刑和
and the years spent underground, now waiting to be washed and identified. I asked him how families typically react to seeing these broken bodies emerge from the ground, after waiting for answers for so long. It's all, he says. Especially when they've spent years trying to learn where their loved ones were buried. Having a real funeral makes a huge difference to people. For a long time, the work of people like Miguel happened below the radar and without support from the state, but then in 2007, a new law went into effect that gave a boost to these
多年埋在地下而破碎，现在等待清洗和鉴定。我问他，家属在等待答案这么久后，看到这些破碎的遗体从地下浮现时通常有什么反应。他说，这太重要了。特别是当他们花了多年时间试图了解亲人被埋在哪里时。举行一场真正的葬礼对人们来说意义重大。长期以来，像米格尔这样的人的工作是在暗中进行的，没有得到国家的支持，但2007年，一项新法律生效，推动了这些
efforts to uncover the crimes of the past. The new law was called the Historical Memory Law, and it broke the pact of forgetting. For the first time, victims of Franco era crimes received official recognition. The law called for the removal of Francoist symbols from public places, and lots of new money flowed to the exclamation efforts happening at mass grave sites across the country. Borifica Fionlapena and her family seized their chance. They contacted Eduardo Ramp, a human rights lawyer, who was helping to investigate crimes
揭露过去罪行的努力。这项新法律被称为《历史记忆法》，它打破了“遗忘协定”。佛朗哥时代罪行的受害者首次获得了官方认可。该法律呼吁从公共场所移除佛朗哥主义符号，大量新资金流入了全国各地万人坑的挖掘工作。普里菲卡·佩尼亚和她的家人抓住了机会。他们联系了人权律师爱德华多·兰兹（Eduardo Ranz），他正在协助调查
dating back to the Franco era. Eduardo started looking into the case of Purification's grandfather and great uncle. He learned, the Purifications relatives were not in a mass grave near the town where they'd been killed. Instead, they were among the bodies that had been moved to the Valley of the Fallen before it opened in 1959. They'd been jumbled together in boxes with other remains and then transferred into the crypts of the Basilica. When reburied, their names had not been written down. And Purifications not been written down. And Purifica Thion's family wasn't the only one hearing this. All told around 33,000
追溯到佛朗哥时代的罪行。爱德华多开始调查普里菲卡的祖父和叔祖父的案件。他了解到，普里菲卡的亲人并不在他们被杀城镇附近的万人坑里。相反，他们是被移送到烈士谷的遗体之一，该地于1959年开放。他们和其他遗骸一起被混装在盒子里，然后转移到了巴西利卡大教堂的地下室。重新安葬时，他们的名字没有被记录下来。普里菲卡的家人并不是唯一听到这个消息的人。总共有大约33,000具
bodies had been reburied at the monument. We were more or less, more or less, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, a new, in 2011, the government asked a panel of experts to consider the future of the valley of the fallen. The panel recommended that Franco's body be removed from the valley. A small victory for those who long said that the valley was a monument to fascism. With Franco's body moved to another cemetery, at least the fascist pilgrimageists would stop. But the panel also said that identifying and removing the tens of thousands of other bodies was not practical.
遗体被重新安葬在纪念碑处。2011年，政府要求一个专家小组考虑烈士谷的未来。专家小组建议将佛朗哥的遗体从山谷中移走。对于那些长期称山谷是法西斯主义纪念碑的人来说，这是一次小小的胜利。随着佛朗哥的遗体被移到另一个墓地，至少法西斯朝圣者会停止前来。但专家小组也表示，鉴定并移走其他数万具遗体是不切实际的。
Purification was once again denied the chance she'd hoped for. It's been so many years, she says. She laments the fact that her father is 95 years old and has lost his memory. He'll never know what happened to his own father. And this is true for thousands of Spaniards. Of all those buried in the valley, 21,000 could be identified. The other 12,000 people remain nameless. The only thing known is where their bodies came from in Spain, offering a small sliver of hope for families still searching for their loved ones.
普里菲卡再次失去了她所希望的机会。她说，已经过去这么多年了。她感叹她的父亲已经95岁，记忆力衰退。他永远不会知道他的父亲发生了什么。对于成千上万的西班牙人来说也是如此。在埋葬在山谷的所有人中，只有21,000人可以被鉴定。其他12,000人仍然无名。唯一已知的是他们的遗体来自西班牙的什么地方，这为仍在寻找亲人的家庭提供了一丝希望。
The efforts to address Spain's fascist past remain patchwork, not just at the valley of the fallen, but across the country. There are still Franco-era statues and street signs, and recently, more insidious reminders of the dictatorship have been re-emerging in the country, a new far-right party known as Vox, one actually claim to be fascist, but their policies align with what Franco represented. They want a border war with Morocco. They want to take away the power held by Spain's regions in favour of national unity. They would deport all undocumented migrants and they're totally opposed to agenda violence law that would tackle Spain's shamefully high levels of domestic violence. Their rapid rise has been driven by Instagram memes and YouTube videos.
解决西班牙法西斯过去的努力仍然是零碎的，不仅在烈士谷，在全国各地也是如此。仍然有佛朗哥时代的雕像和街道标志，最近，独裁统治更阴险的提醒正在国内重新出现，一个名为“Vox”的新极右翼政党，虽然没有公开声称是法西斯，但他们的政策与佛朗哥所代表的立场一致。他们想要与摩洛哥进行边境战争。他们想要剥夺西班牙各地区拥有的权力，以支持国家统一。他们会驱逐所有无证移民，并且完全反对旨在解决西班牙高得令人羞愧的家庭暴力水平的性别暴力法。他们的迅速崛起是由Instagram模因和YouTube视频推动的。
A recent election spot showed the party's leader Santiago Abascal striding through a Castilian landscape and talking about honor and national pride and about refusing to live among traders. Vox puts on a fence which attract a lot of young people who have never voted before, and many of them don't even know who Franco is. In a lot of ways, the pact of forgetting actually worked. Recent history isn't taught in Spanish schools, which means that young people are more susceptible to Vox's appeal. They don't understand the party's connection to Spain's bloody history.
最近的一个竞选广告显示，该党领导人圣地亚哥·阿巴斯卡尔（Santiago Abascal）走在卡斯蒂利亚的风景中，谈论荣誉、民族自豪感以及拒绝与叛徒生活在一起。Vox设置的围栏吸引了许多从未投过票的年轻人，他们中许多人甚至不知道佛朗哥是谁。在很多方面，“遗忘协定”确实起作用了。西班牙学校不教授近代史，这意味着年轻人更容易受到Vox的吸引。他们不了解该党与西班牙血腥历史的联系。
Faustal canales, the left-wing activist, says his own father is believed to be in the valley of the fallen, but every attempt to get him out has been blocked. After living with the pain of his father's murder, his entire life, Faustal has watched Fox's rise with increasing alarm. Spanish is the country of memory.
左翼活动家福斯托·卡纳莱斯说，他自己的父亲被认为在烈士谷，但每一次带他出来的尝试都被阻止了。在经历了父亲被谋杀的痛苦一生后，福斯托带着日益增长的警惕注视着Vox的崛起。西班牙是记忆的国家。
It was forgotten. All this drama that happened, all this genocide. He says Spain is the country of amnesia. So much tragedy, a genocide has been forgotten. After Franco's body was removed from the valley, Vox accused the government of using the exhumation to score political points ahead of an election, drowning out the calls from families to take their own loved ones out of the monument. Meanwhile, pro-Franco protesters gathered at the valley and sang Spain's old national
它被遗忘了。所有这些发生的戏剧，所有这些种族灭绝。他说西班牙是健忘的国家。太多的悲剧，一场种族灭绝被遗忘了。佛朗哥的遗体从山谷移走后，Vox指责政府利用挖掘来在选举前获取政治分数，淹没了家属要求将亲人从纪念碑中带出来的呼声。与此同时，亲佛朗哥的抗议者聚集在山谷，唱起了西班牙的旧国歌，
anthem, which is peppered with fascist lyrics. The anthem was retired after Franco died, in favour of a wordless melody you just not not along to. But now they're singing the lyrics again. Opinion is now divided on what the future of the valley should be. The government has been spending a lot of money to keeping in good shape the monument. Stop it. Not that I'm more. Once all the bodies are out, Nikolus would leave nature to take its course. Just let the monument fall down. The only problem is that nature works, but it works very slowly.
其中充斥着法西斯歌词。这首国歌在佛朗哥死后被废除，取而代之的是一首无词旋律，你只能跟着哼唱。但现在他们又开始唱起那些歌词了。关于山谷的未来应该是什么，舆论现在出现了分歧。政府一直在花费大量资金来保持纪念碑的良好状态。停止吧。尼古拉斯说，一旦所有遗体都被移走，就让大自然顺其自然吧。让纪念碑倒塌。唯一的问题是，大自然虽然在起作用，但速度非常缓慢。
Borificación says the most important thing is to get the rest of the bodies out of the valley, not just frankers. I want everyone to have a certain kind of life. She says, what I want is for every family with murdered victims in the valley of the fallen or thrown in ditches. I want them to dig up all of these people buried all over Spain,
普里菲卡说，最重要的事情是把剩下的遗体从山谷中移走，不仅仅是佛朗哥的。她说，我希望每个人都能过上某种生活。我想要的是，每一个在烈士谷有被谋杀亲人或被扔进沟里的家庭，我希望他们挖掘出所有埋在西班牙各地的这些人，
because Spain is a mass grave. My idea would be to exume them all and for them to be given back to their families and dignified with burials and cemeteries where they should be. The story of what really happened should be known and taught in schools so that everyone knows the real history of what happened. In 2016, a judge ordered an exhumation of Porofa Castellón's family members. It was the first and only time that it happened in Spain. But it still hasn't been carried out. Porofa Castellón and Faustal were told that, with Franco's body gone, this might be the
因为西班牙就是一个万人坑。我的想法是把他们全部挖掘出来，归还给他们的家人，并在他们应该安葬的墓地给予尊严的安葬。关于真正发生了什么的故事应该被知晓，并在学校里教授，这样每个人都知道所发生之事的真实历史。2016年，一名法官下令挖掘普里菲卡家人的遗体。这是西班牙第一次也是唯一一次发生这种情况。但它仍然没有执行。普里菲卡和福斯托被告知，随着佛朗哥的遗体离开，这可能是
year. And while they're not getting their hopes up, it's true that in Spain, the dead have a way of surprising living. Coming up after the break, Nicolas Sanchez Albernos, the student who was sentenced to work at the Valley of the Fallen, well, he eventually escaped. And the story of how that happened is pretty wild. Stay with us.
这一年。虽然他们没有抱太大希望，但在西班牙，死者确实有一种让生者感到惊讶的方式。休息后，尼古拉斯·桑切斯·阿尔沃诺斯，那个被判在烈士谷服苦役的学生，他最终逃脱了。关于那件事的故事非常疯狂。请继续关注。
So as a reminder, Nikolas Sanchez-Albernaus was the student who was imprisoned at the Valley of the Fallen for a few months during its construction. He didn't do hard labor, he worked in an office job there, but it was an awful place, and a lot of prisoners tried to escape. It's estimated there are 50 attempted escapes between 1940 and 1959. But the only two escapes that succeeded were those of my friend and myself, the rest were cops.
提醒一下，尼古拉斯·桑切斯·阿尔沃诺斯是那个在烈士谷建设期间被监禁了几个月的学生。他没有做苦力，他在那里做办公室工作，但那是一个可怕的地方，许多囚犯试图逃跑。据估计，1940年至1959年间有50次逃跑尝试。但唯一成功的两次逃跑是我朋友和我，其余的都被抓住了。
And how Nicholas did it is a pretty crazy story. So we wanted to bring back Jennifer O'Monnie to tell us a bit more. And so Jennifer, tell us what happened with this escape. So to begin with, there were a few things that made escaping from the valley of the fallen difficult. The valley wasn't actually really heavily guarded, but it was set very deep in a forest. And if anybody managed to walk out, they get picked up as soon as they got to the nearest road. And if anybody managed to walk out, they get picked up as soon as they got to the nearest road. And in Spain at that time, the roads were really heavily policed, and Spaniards needed
尼古拉斯是怎么做到的，这是一个非常疯狂的故事。所以我们想请回詹妮弗·奥马尼来告诉我们更多信息。詹妮弗，告诉我们这次逃跑发生了什么。首先，有几件事使得从烈士谷逃跑变得困难。山谷实际上并没有严密守卫，但它位于森林深处。如果有人设法走出来，他们一到达最近的公路就会被抓。在当时的西班牙，道路受到严密监控，西班牙人需要
special permission to just to travel around their own country. So if an escape prisoner even made it out to the road, there was little chance they'd be able to make it any further because of all the guards. It would be very difficult. So Nicolas understood that context, and he reached out to a good friend of his, an architect who drafted him some fake travel permits. And the next thing Nicolas did was write a letter to some of his friends who were exiled in Paris. And he asked them if they could help him get out of the valley. And those friends just happened to be connected
特别许可才能在自己的国家旅行。所以如果一个逃跑的囚犯即使到了路上，因为所有的守卫，他们几乎没有机会走得更远。这会非常困难。所以尼古拉斯理解这种背景，他联系了一位好朋友，一位为他起草了假旅行证件的建筑师。尼古拉斯做的下一件事是写信给他在巴黎流亡的一些朋友。他问他们是否能帮他离开山谷。而那些朋友恰好与
to Norman Meila. Norman Meila, the author? Like, I mean, was he was he already famous at this point? Yeah, this was just before his debut novel came out. So he wasn't quite famous yet, but he was just on the cusp of it. And he was one of a number of writers and artists from the US who'd got very interested in the anti-fascist movement in Europe. Fascism goes back to our infancy and our childhood where we were always told how to live. We'll tell do this, don't do that. No, no.
诺曼·梅勒有联系。诺曼·梅勒，那位作家？我的意思是，他当时已经出名了吗？是的，这就在他的处女作小说出版之前。所以他还没那么出名，但正处于成名边缘。他是美国许多对欧洲反法西斯运动非常感兴趣的作家和艺术家之一。法西斯主义可以追溯到我们的婴儿期和童年，那时我们总是被告知如何生活。我们会被告知做这个，不要做那个。不，不。
Yes, you may do that. No, you may not do that. That's a very Norman Mayler take on fascism. No. So how did he get connected to Nicholas's friend? Well, according to Nicholas, apparently, Mahler was on holiday in France, and he'd had a chance encounter with his friends. Mahler mentioned he'd be going back to the US quite soon
是的，你可以做那个。不，你不可以做那个。那是诺曼·梅勒对法西斯主义的看法。不。那么他是怎么和尼古拉斯的朋友联系上的呢？好吧，据尼古拉斯说，显然，梅勒当时在法国度假，他与他的朋友们有过一次偶然的相遇。梅勒提到他很快就要回美国了，
that he'd bought a car, and he was trying to get rid of it before he left. And our friend said, well, we need your car. And he said, well, I give it to you, but I also will give you my sister to drive. So that would be Mela's sister, Barbara, who had also been in France. And she was also interested in the anti-fascist movement, and she began corresponding with Nicolas Vaya, his friends. They wrote letters back and forth,
他买了一辆车，在离开前想把它处理掉。我们的朋友说，我们需要你的车。他说，好吧，我把它给你们，但我也会让我妹妹开车送你们。那就是梅勒的妹妹芭芭拉，她也曾在法国。她也对反法西斯运动感兴趣，并开始与尼古拉斯的朋友通信。他们来回写信，
and eventually they agreed on a date and time when she'd come to the valley in Norman Mela's car, driven by one of Nicolas's friends to take him away. And that sounds like kind of surprisingly easy. Yeah, so the fact that Barbara was an American and the fact they were in a car, in a strange way, it meant they aroused much less suspicion. That seems to be kind of like the benefits of being an American. That situation.
最终他们商定了一个日期和时间，她会开着诺曼·梅勒的车，由尼古拉斯的一位朋友驾驶，来到山谷带走他。这听起来出奇地容易。是的，芭芭拉是美国人，而且他们有一辆车，这在某种程度上意味着他们引起的怀疑要少得多。这似乎是作为美国人的好处。那种情况。
Yeah, well, at this time, almost any foreigner really had a certain amount of privilege in that respect. So on the appointed date, Nicolas and a friend of his from university, who's also jailed for pro-democracy activities, snuck out of his barracks and found Barbara waiting for them with their mutual friends. They were just parked there in front of the monument. There was just like sitting outside,
是的，在那个时候，几乎任何外国人在那方面确实都有一定的特权。所以在约定的日期，尼古拉斯和他在大学的一位朋友（也因支持民主活动被监禁）溜出营房，找到了正在等他们的芭芭拉和他们的共同朋友。他们就停在纪念碑前。他们就坐在外面，
they beep a couple of times and they come running out. Yeah, according to how he tells it, Nicolas and the fellow prisoner hopped into the car and then Barbara drove them to Northeastern Spain and dropped them at the border with France. Then there was a hard part. Nicolas had to hike with his friend through the Pyrenees mountains for three days,
他们按了几下喇叭，他们就跑了出来。是的，据他讲述，尼古拉斯和另一名囚犯跳进车里，然后芭芭拉开车把他们送到西班牙东北部，把他们放在了法国边境。然后是困难的部分。尼古拉斯不得不和他的朋友徒步穿越比利牛斯山脉三天，
walking only at night and hiding out or sleeping during the day to avoid police. They were trying to be as inconspicuous as possible. And finally, on the third day, they saw a road sign written in French. It was written in French and we felt an all-the-fresh man with a long mustache that we began to talk with him and he said, oh, no, you're safe, you're in France. And so was it typical for people fleeing Franco Spain to go into France seeking safety? I mean, like, were there lots of people hiking
只在晚上行走，白天躲藏或睡觉以避开警察。他们试图尽可能不引人注目。终于，在第三天，他们看到了一个用法语写的路标。它是用法语写的，我们感到……一个留着长胡子的法国人，我们开始和他交谈，他说，哦，不，你们安全了，你们在法国。那么，逃离佛朗哥西班牙的人去法国寻求安全是典型的做法吗？我的意思是，有很多人徒步
to the Pyrenees, just as Nicolas did? Well, Nicolas was following a route established by hundreds of thousands of political refugees, actually. When the Republican forces lost their last battle to Franco's nationalist army in 1939. So at that time, men, women and children made their way into France through the mountains. But by the time Nicolas made that journey, it was a lot less common. I mean, Spain wasn't a totally closed country like North Korea, but he was a fugitive, so it was
去比利牛斯山脉吗，就像尼古拉斯那样？嗯，尼古拉斯走的是数十万政治难民建立的路线。当共和党军队在1939年输掉与佛朗哥民族主义军队的最后一场战斗时。那时，男人、女人和孩子通过山脉进入法国。但当尼古拉斯进行那次旅程时，这已经不那么常见了。我的意思是，西班牙不像朝鲜那样是一个完全封闭的国家，但他是一个逃犯，所以对他来说
a bit different for him. And so what did Nicolas do once he got into France? Well, as any of us would, I guess, he got in touch with his family and his father, a diplomat who was in exile for his own safety, told him to come to Argentina, so Nicolas flew out and reunited with his family there and he wouldn't return to Spain until Franco's death. No, that's a cool story.
有点不同。那么尼古拉斯到了法国后做了什么？好吧，我想我们任何人都会这样做，他联系了他的家人，他的父亲，一位为了自身安全而流亡的外交官，告诉他去阿根廷，所以尼古拉斯飞往那里与家人团聚，直到佛朗哥去世他才回到西班牙。不，那是一个很酷的故事。
Alright, thanks so much Jennifer, I appreciate it. Thanks a lot Roman. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Jennifer Ommani and edited by Senior Producer Delaney Hall. Mixed by Bryson Barnes. Music by Sean Riel. Kurt Colstet is the digital director of the rest of the team. Is Vivian Le,
好的，非常感谢Jennifer，我很感激。非常感谢Roman。《99% Invisible》本周由Jennifer Ommani制作，由高级制作人Delaney Hall编辑。混音由Bryson Barnes完成。音乐由Sean Riel创作。Kurt Colstet是团队其余成员的数字总监。还有Vivian Le，
Chris Baroube, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Katie Mingle, Abby Madon, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Roe, which is now distributed in multiple locations around North America, but in our hearts will always be. In beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listener supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Find them all at radiotopia.fm.
Chris Baroube、Joe Rosenberg、Emmett Fitzgerald、Katie Mingle、Abby Madon、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Radio Roe制作，现在在北美多个地点发行，但在我们心中，它永远属于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。我们是PRX旗下Radio Topia的骄傲成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性、听众支持、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的独立集体。请访问radiotopia.fm了解更多信息。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99pi or a current Instagram and read it too. You can find out how to pre-order the 99% invisible book that we announced last week at 99pi.org slash book and for all your other 99pi needs, look no further than 99pi.org. needs. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99pi，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上关注我们。你可以在99pi.org/book上了解如何预订我们上周宣布的《99% Invisible》书籍。对于所有其他关于99pi的需求，请访问99pi.org。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。